Yeah, so while we wait for it to come up
cuz I know we're short of time, I'm
going to talk about
agents on device. So I know whoever
asked the question about skills and AI
core, we have an answer to that. We've
built a simple skill harness on top of
AI core that you can build skills on.
We'll be able to show that. Also going
to talk about tiny LLMs which are we
would call LLMs that are like smaller
than a billion parameters. They're small
enough to build into your app if you
want to have more customization or you
want to do something that isn't already
available for you in AI core. So that's
the gist. So
quick overview of AI edge, well, how we
think about small language models, tiny
LLMs, and system gen AI.
Then we're going to take a quick look at
agent skills which is something we can
build on top of of kind of system gen AI
or the new models that are coming down
the pipe. Um and then we're going to
take a quick look at tiny models.
So that's that. Okay, so cool.
Yeah.
Cool.
Yeah, I'll
Okay.
Yeah, feel free.
Um okay. So AI edge SLMs and TLMs.
Okay, so I think Ali already covered
this. We know it's great to do things on
device, latency, privacy, offline use,
reliability, or savings depending on
thing These are all motivations to do
things locally.
Um me by way of intro, I didn't really
do this.
I kind of I'm
a software engineering kind of tech lead
working on the Google AI edge stack. So
that's
We have MediaPipe which is an asset some
people may be familiar with. We have
lighter TLM which is a LLM harness that
you can integrate with your app. Um
where you download the model and ship
the model with your app. And then we
also have kind of lighter T as a runtime
that supports both lighter T L M and
MediaPipe. Uh, it's kind of formerly
known as TensorFlow Lite, which is a
kind of cross-framework runtime for
running um, models. And all of that can
run on CPU, GPU, or NPU, uh, depending
on the platform and depending what's
best. And you as a developer get to
choose.
Uh, yeah, it's already trusted at scale.
Um, like the lighter T runtime, there's
a version of that built into Android OS.
Uh, lots of Android apps already use it.
So, so it does uh, support over 2.7
billion devices, like lots and lots of
daily invocations, and lots and lots of
Android apps uh, leverage this.
Uh, but also works far beyond Android as
well. So, we support all of these
platforms. Um, and uh, for example,
Gemma is available on many of these
platforms. Our team like uh, is giving
another talk tomorrow, so you can hear
more about Gemma performance on all of
these types of platforms and are able to
do uh, really useful things with the
latest Gemma 4 models.
Um, but then building on Ollie's and
Florina's talk, this is kind of key idea
is that we have um, system-level GenAI,
which is something that will be
pre-installed in the system. So, there's
Gemini Nano via AI Core. This is an
example of the summarization API. Um,
Apple also has something going on with
their intelligence on iOS that I
probably know a lot less about. Um, but
as a concept, right? Um, as an app
developer, when you go to build a mobile
app, this is kind of one choice is there
will often be an
some form of intelligence built into the
system that you can leverage. Um, which
is uh, you know, highly optimized as
kind of Ollie and Florina covered, and
that's available for use with your app.
Um, then, so this is kind of typically
like small language models like for
for Nano, it is the Gemma 4 E2B and E4B
are the base models for for what we ship
there.
That's really capable, highly optimized,
preloaded with device. If you can use
those, it's great. Your app doesn't get
any bigger. And if it meets your use
case needs, it's a great place to start.
If you want like more
uh if you have a more specific task um
that you want to do that's kind of
highly customized or something really
boutique,
um you can use an App Gen AP Gen AI. So,
that's with the lighter TLN runtime. Uh
that can be loaded with your app or even
your web page, right? Um and this offers
kind of a higher degree of customization
and reach. Like definitely more work. Um
but uh yeah, you kind of access to uh
smaller models that can run on lots of
devices. Um and full customization.
Though, it's clearly a lot more work,
but it's the other option that's
available.
Okay.
So,
uh rest of the talk uh 15 minutes going
to cover two key ideas. One is um hey,
how do you do skills on device cuz this
is something new that we can do with
Gemma 4 that came out last week. We've a
few examples of that. This is one key
idea. The other idea I want to cover is
hey, for tiny models, what can you
actually do with those types of models
today because we've actually made a lot
of progress in this in the last 6 to 12
months. So, I kind of just want to share
what's the state of the art with tiny
LLMs. And if you want to use one in your
app, how would you go about that?
Okay.
So, this is wow, there's a lot on the
screen. This is um
uh an app that our team have developed
that works on both iOS and Android for
running LLMs locally.
Um and here we show both really tiny
LLMs so you can see what they can do,
but also cuz Gemma 4 just came out,
we're also using this to showcase what
how Gemma 4 can work um on Android and
iOS as well. And this actually builds on
AI Core. When AI Core is available on
the device, it will use AI Core to kind
of
provide the Gemma model for the app.
So, skills is the thing I want to kind
of go into deeply today, but there's a
bunch of other things in the app. like
you can do AI chat, you can ask image,
you can do audio scribe, and there's
lots of example models, and the app also
supports 3P models, like kind of
quan or phi or these types of models. If
you just want to load a model, get a
feel for how it performs on device.
And this app is also open source on
Android, and it's built using lighter
GLM. So, it's both a neat way for you to
try things out, but also if you're keen,
you can kind of dive into the code and
see, "Hey, how does it all kind of hang
together?" as an example for lighter
GLM.
All right, but
we're going to dive into skills, cuz
this is kind of a topic du jour.
Okay, I'm not going to play this video
cuz I don't have enough time. But yeah,
this app is available Android, iOS,
code available on GitHub as well.
Um let me just take a picture.
Okay.
Um
Okay, and the app is called Google AI
Edge Gallery.
So, this is the video you will watch cuz
it's shorter and meets my time budget.
And we don't
Could we get sounds?
>> one agent task.
>> Sorry, I'll go
Please reply to me in English.
So, this uses a restaurant related
skill.
And we'll see how that's built in a
moment.
Let's have a look at the restaurants.
Select one.
Winner, right? So, that's an example of
something neat that you can build like
with a simple agent harness on top of
Gemma 4 that's like
really just a few line like pretty easy
to do with a few lines of code or a few
lines of the right vibe coding prompt as
you'll see in a minute.
Okay.
Okay, I don't know how that
Ah, yeah.
Okay.
Uh
Okay, I kind of got lost a little bit.
Okay.
All right, sorry. Back back back to
where we're was to be. So, what's
actually happening under the hood? So,
like I was saying, this is built on like
um
this is built just using a prompt,
right? And here you can provide We have
our own system prompts in our app. Uh
then we also put the skill descriptions
into the prompt. So, the um
so the model is aware of the types of
skills it can use, but it doesn't have
to see all of the functions and details
of the skill. That's only kind of loaded
on demand.
Um
so, we actually have a a load uh a load
skill tool call built into the model
that then like selectively, so if you
say, "Hey, can you show us the location
of the Google office?" It will then
know, "Wow, I should use the map skill."
It then loads the skill for map
navigation.
Um
the tool responds, and then it uses the
show JS tool
um to show you the location um
in the app as well. So, one of the
things that's neat about being in an app
is you can put simple JavaScript into
the skill that we then call as part of
the skill. Uh so, this is how like I
don't have the corresponding demo for
this, but this would kind of pop up a
nice um
uh
kind of like JavaScript UI of kind of
Google Maps to kind of just show you uh
in the app right there. Uh similar to
the restaurant roulette, that was a
custom JavaScript uh to do the rendering
to do the uh roulette wheel piece.
Okay, so you can create your own skill
as well. Um the app supports this.
Uh sorry. Oh, yeah. Instructions on
GitHub. I don't know if I can get past
this page too fast.
Uh but also um I just create your own
skill, there's full instructions there
if you want to kind of hand write it
out.
Uh this works really well though. Uh so,
you can use skills to write skills. So,
we have um
Gemini CLI or code coach like our team
have done like about 80 skills and had a
lot of fun with this.
Um
so, this is an example of a prompt which
works really reliably. Um in Gemini CLI,
we actually have an ADB skill as well um
that that we our team uses a lot. So,
you can even debug and test by saying,
"Hey, you have access to a device
um via ADB and you can um also ask to
test uh that." So, this type of thing
actually works really really well and
it's fun and you can then create a skill
and then in the app there's a dot dot
dot button and you can go to load your
own skill from a URL if you kind of
publish it your custom to your own
GitHub. And it's kind of really easy to
do from within the app.
Uh you can then also uh let us know in
our discussion on GitHub um that you've
created a skill and then other people
can check out your skill and kind of use
that as well. So, these are some things
This has only been out like since last
Thursday, but these are some example
skills that the community have built.
So, feel free to do it and tag it up
here.
Okay, so that's skills. So, 10 The last
10 minutes we are going to spend on TLMs
um or probably more ideally maybe five
or six of the minutes, so there's time
for questions.
Okay, so lighter TLM, this is the
runtime that we have that um
we use for running models. It runs
models in lighter or TLM format, which
is a single file that packages
everything we need to know about the
model in order to be able to run it.
Uh it's open source, it's fast and it
works on multiple platforms.
Uh and there is a Swift API and a
JavaScript API coming soon. At the
moment, if you go to the GitHub, you can
see the C++ and Java version. And when
we publish the Swift version, we will
also publish
um we'll also open source the iOS app at
that point in time. So, if you go to
gallery for at the moment, you can only
see the code for Android, but um
hopefully in the next few weeks um
where uh we can get the Swift work
finished, have a really good API and
then we'll be able to
um open source that as well.
So, yeah, and it supports Java 4 as well
on all of these devices. Uh it also
supports loads of other models, but
understandably Java 4 is our favorite.
Um
so then to deploy uh tiny model, what do
you do? So, typically starting
transformers, you then have a package
called lighter or T torch that can help
you export the model and then lighter or
TLM. There's actually a reference
version of that that you can use on your
desktop as well if you want to try out a
model.
You can either try it out on a desktop
or you can load it into the gallery and
see it perform there. And then you can
deploy with lighter or TLM.
It's worth noting for smaller models,
you would either pick a fixed function
model like visual language model or a
transcription model or something like
this. So, there are some pre-built
models available on our on our
on our transformers page that you can
use. But, something we also see that's
really common is people fine-tuning
models um because
certainly once you get down to like 200
or 100 million parameters,
for that model to work, it needs to have
a very narrow and focused task and um
we've had a lot of success deploying
those models internally and in an app a
different app that you're going to see
in a minute
um by doing kind of fine-tuning using
synthetic data.
So, this is what the export and
inference flow looks like. So, this is
um
this is showing okay, on the left-hand
side it's showing us exporting a quant
0.6 model and then running that um on
desktop with lighter or TLM run so you
can just see how that behaves using a
GPU for example. Uh the right-hand side
is showing a
different example which is Apple's fast
VLM.
Um this is a visual language model
that's only 500 million parameters and
this is optimized and running on like a
um
this is running on the Qualcomm NPU
that's also available through our stack
NPU optimization. So, this is an example
of that happening end-to-end. And this
is running really quick cuz it's using
hardware acceleration. And this is model
is just that particular model is 500
million parameters by way of example.
Another example that we've spent a bunch
of time with uh the DeepMind team on was
publishing function journal. It's
something we published last uh December.
This was based on Gemma 3 technology.
This is only 270 million parameters,
but it's robust function calling when
fine-tuned, typo there.
And this is then it's small and it's
really fast even on legacy devices. So,
if you go all the way back to a Pixel 7,
they still can process almost 2,000
tokens per second prefill and 140
decode. So, it's really useful for lots
of
It's really useful for lots of simple
use cases, like you can do text to
function calling or voice to function
calling using this size model.
And there is a whole YouTube video on
this called Function Gemma.
If you want to find out lots more
details about how to do it. We also from
um
have a function Gemma fine-tuning lab.
So, if you search function Gemma
fine-tuning lab, I don't have
here.
This is available as a hugging face
space. You can kind of import, you can
define functions, upload your own data,
and
see how they kind of fine-tune function
Gemma. And this is kind of recommended
for really high for really robust
function calling. So, we have an example
in the app called
like app intents where it'll do like
this the thing you saw previously of
like add calendar or add email.
So, when we took function Gemma out of
the box, our success rate in that was
I think 40 6% or something like that.
Then we put it through this fine-tuning
flow where we're like, "Hey, we have
these app functions."
And instead of providing that via a
system prompt, which is what you would
do if you're using a larger model or if
you're on a device with AI core, for
example, um
but
um you instead need to kind of
synthetically create a data set, right?
It's It's typically the workflow. We use
flash to synthetically create a data
set. Um
upload it to this type of tool or we
obviously have our own internal tools,
but that then got that 46% um to over
like it was over 90% for eight of the 10
functions we were trying and two of the
functions were a bit lower in their kind
of ACs.
Um, so you can get really robust and
reliable function calling using this
fine tuning workflow. Yes, it's it's a
bit more work than just prompting a
larger model,
um, but it does allow you to kind of
ship something robust in your app at
scale.
Oh, sorry, going the wrong direction.
Oh, yeah. So then pre-built uh, tiny
models are here.
Um,
yeah, okay. I'm going to pull stop for
questions. Okay, so we have and I don't
want to go to the details. We have
another app I'll just speed run this for
1 minute. We also have another app
called Eloquent, which is a
transcription service. Um, but what's
more interesting than the app was just
an example of like how we built that. So
it also supports things like
personalization. So it does
transcription with with your own
favorite keywords. So if you use a lot
of like tech jargon or a lot of people's
names, transcription service don't
always get that correct. Um,
sadly this is only available on iOS and
not available in Europe yet, right? So
this will be increasingly available uh,
soon.
But the more interesting thing for the
purpose of this conversation is under
the hood,
this is something we've built using tiny
LLMs ourselves. So this uses a ASR
engine that we have built based on Gemma
3 technology and then it also has like
something we call like a text polishing
engine that we've also built uh, with
Gemma 3 technology. And both each of
these models are only a few hundred
million parameters, uh, but chained
together they can create a really
compelling offline like offline
transcription service that is able to
leverage a personal dictionary, right?
And also like the polishing also removes
ums and ahs and that sort of stuff,
right? which is also a common gripe with
kind of um, kind of offline
transcription apps. But yeah, so not
really available widely yet. It'll be
available in but for the purpose of this
conversation, it's more just like a
proof of life example. So, like this
does work in production. Once you put in
the effort to kind of fine-tune a model
and you can create pretty compelling
things.
Okay, so that's not available in iOS in
Europe so that's out of the equation.
So, yeah. Takeaways, system gen AI and
app gen AI, that's the kind of the
overall
yeah, overall kind of message and wrap
up. Happy to take questions. I have 3
whole minutes.
Uh I think person there was first.
Um yeah, we are still putting models on
the clock there.
Uh so, we've literally been playing with
a model for about 2 to 3 weeks now. It's
been in public for about 1 week. We we
see like within a single conver So, we
can provide like certainly for the 4
billion parameter model, like if you by
default we enable about eight skills and
it's able to choose between the eight
skills reasonably well, right? Um
within a conversation
you're able to say, "Hey, like you know,
like um like find me out a fact on using
a Wikipedia scale. Then, oh wow, show me
where that is on Google Maps." So, if
you have a conversation that uses skill,
skill, skill, that works really
robustly. The thing we're still working
on that's harder is through a single
like um interaction with the app for the
app to know to call multiple skills as
part of a single answer. That's um that
works sometimes, right? And we're still
like that's something we're still
figuring out how to make that more
robust, right? Um but yeah, like it's
all in a
just our like our engine harness thing
is really simple. So, I'm sure we'll
figure that out, but we're still kind of
discovering the limits of how far we can
push the model.
Uh yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. Light or TLM file format for just
for stock
LLM is effectively a replacement for dot
task file. That's a transition we made
last year. Dot task files are still
useful for things like
like a task file creates more things
than just an LLM model, right? So there
is like a face mesh task and obviously
that has a lot of other code as well.
But for LLMs we want something
dedicated, simpler that people can use
with open developer tooling.
Yeah. So yeah, so it bundles things like
the tokenizer but it's just the LLM
model. Okay.
Yeah.
On TPU?
CPU? Um
Yeah. So there is another talk tomorrow
from some of my colleagues including Wei
who's here in second row and that has
lots of performance data
on Gemma and various models on
Yeah. You can also check out our model
card in the meantime if you search Gemma
light or TLM model card. We
we keep it kind of running like we
update that whenever we have new
performance numbers on new platforms. So
there's a lot of comprehensive data
there as well.
All right. I'm at zero seconds and it's
flashing at me.
Yeah.
Yeah. I was at 2:30. Sorry. Chinchin's
here. Sorry Chinchin. Didn't see you.